this is a collaboration video with
real-life lore be sure to follow the
link at the end of this video to check
out his work
this is earth every human being that's
ever lived has called it home a
seemingly Loden bastion of life in an
otherwise barren universe earth is
something very special
despite our best efforts we've never
detected any form of life beyond our
pale blue dot why is that what
attributes make planet earth a better
host for life than any other celestial
body first and foremost in the presence
of liquid water based on our current
understanding liquid water is a
prerequisite for life as we know it
thanks to a number of crucial factors
not present on other planets earth is
perfectly suited for water the primary
factor we're going to consider is the
Earth's location relative to the Sun our
little blue planet resides in what's
called the habitable zone which is the
range of orbits around a star within
which a planet could support liquid
water
given sufficient atmospheric pressure
this limited band is often aptly
referred to as the Goldilocks zone any
closer to the star and the planet is too
hot any further and it's too cold
luckily for us the planet Earth sits
comfortably within the habitable zone of
our Sun because of this prime galactic
real estate earth has played host to a
dazzling array of life-forms from single
cells all the way to incredibly complex
beings
you might be thinking with all the
billions of other planets out there
surely earth can't be the only one so
perfect for life can it on February 22nd
2017 NASA held a press conference to
reveal some very exciting news this is
Trappist one it's an ultra-cool dwarf
star about 40 light-years away in the
Aquarius constellation astronomers first
discovered three earth sized planets
orbiting the small star back in 2015
NASA's exciting announcement not only
did they discover four new exoplanets
bringing the total to seven but three of
those planets fall well within the
habitable zone of Trappist one let's
take a look at the full roster here they
are in all their glory Trappist b c d e
f g and h not exactly the most elegant
names but we'll make do for now part of
what makes these planets so exciting is
that they're all rocky like Earth and
they all have a radius between 0.75 and
1.0 eight times that of Earth
of these seven planets e F and G orbit
within the habitable zone this habitable
zone is quite different from that of our
own Sun as Trappist is significantly
dimmer and less powerful this means that
even though all seven planets orbit
closer to their star than mercury orbits
the Sun the comparatively mild radiation
from Trappist still allows for potential
liquid water as exciting as that
possibility is it's important to note
that these planets are suspected to be
tidally locked when a celestial body is
tidally locked it always faces the same
direction much like the Earth's moon
that means that one side of each planet
receives all the radiation from Trappist
and the other side remains in perpetual
darkness since Trappist one is so
relatively mild a star it's not yet
certain whether it's planets would
suffer from extreme heat on one
Hemisphere and extreme cold on the other
however even if that is the case it's
thought that a proper atmosphere on any
of these planets would help dissipate
the heat and allow for a milder climate
as fascinating as the discovery itself
is what's equally fascinating is
considering what life would be like on a
Trappist planet what would it be like to
stand on the surface one of the first
things you would notice is that the
light is significantly dimmer on
Trappist planets since Trappist one is
an ultra-cool dwarf star most of its
radiation is in the form of infrared
wavelengths rather than visible
wavelengths according to NASA's report
the dayside of Trappist planets would
never get brighter than Earth's skies
just after sunset once you got used to
this perpetual Twilight and looked out
into space you would see something
remarkable from any given Trappist
planet you would be able to see most of
your planetary neighbors drifting across
the sky and they wouldn't be tiny specks
of light like Mars as to us from a
Trappist world you'd be able to see the
texture on your neighbor planets much
like we can see the craters on the moon
think about it someday far into the
future residents of one planet could
look up into space and see the
criss-crossing lights of civilization on
their neighboring planet imagine one day
a child is born on Trappist F since
these exoplanets are so close to their
star it takes in almost no time at all
to complete their orbit that means that
on Trappist F little Johnny will be
celebrating his birthday every nine days
as of right now we can't see the
Trappist planets directly to get
detailed findings on what their terrain
or atmospheres are like luckily with the
James Webb telescope launching in 2018
astronomers will be able to more
accurate
the chemical makeup of each planet's
atmosphere newer telescopes like the
James Webb will be able to assess the
greenhouse gas content of the
atmospheres and give scientists a better
understanding of surface conditions on
the planets the ideal scenario would be
discovering the presence of what are
referred to as bio signatures such as
methane or ozone the presence of such
bio signatures would be a strong
indication of past or present life the
star itself is classified as an M dwarf
star this is extremely promising for the
possibility of life an M dwarf star is
known for burning very slowly and at
very low temperatures the lowest of any
other type of star this means that they
can burn for up to trillions of years
unlike larger hotter stars like our Sun
which have a lifespan measured in
billions or tens of billions of years
what does that mean for the possibility
of life well if Trappist one has been
providing warmth to its planets for such
a vast amount of time that means life
has had ample opportunity to emerge or
even develop into more complex forms if
life is actually discovered in the
Trappist system it bodes well for the
existence of life elsewhere in the
universe not only because we would have
found one example of it but because M
dwarf stars are among the most plentiful
varieties of star with billions of M
dwarf stars in the universe providing
warmth to billions of planets over
incalculable stretches of time just
imagine the potential for life out there
among the stars with the launch of the
James Webb telescope fast approaching
we're in for a very exciting next few
years
imagine the significance of discovering
life in the Trappist one system not only
would the great question of are we alone
finally be answered but the discoveries
we make on the Trappist planets would
dramatically increase our understanding
of habitable planets and pave the way to
greater and more frequent discoveries in
the future who knows maybe the
discoveries we make in the next few
years will lead us to the greatest
discovery of all a planet just as
suitable to life as Earth it's all
incredibly exciting and Trappist one is
just the beginning these seven
exoplanets are just a tiny fraction of
the confirmed number outside our solar
system many of them are far stranger and
more exotic than the worlds of Trappist
one you can learn more about the amazing
variety of planets in the universe by
checking out this video by real-life
lore where he explores the incredible
things you could see and do that would
be impossible on earth thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video
you